bueno
[Música]
el mismo día del ataque de pearl harbor
japón llevó a cabo un ataque combinado
contra hong kong filipinas tailandia y
malasia fue el día 7 de diciembre de
1941 tras tomar el control de hong kong
el ejército japonés interno en campos de
prisioneros a los administradores de la
colonia y a muchos ciudadanos británicos
y estadounidenses sustituyó el dólar de
hong kong por el yen militar y confiscó
todas las instalaciones de producción y
comercio de la ciudad
durante los 4 años de ocupación japonesa
la economía de hong kong se fue a pique
se arruinó y la población se redujo a la
mitad pero el día 15 de agosto de 1945
finalmente tras la durísima guerra del
pacifico se terminó la segunda guerra
mundial
japón se rindió y hong kong volvió a
pasar a manos de los británicos
[Música]
a partir de ese momento comenzaría una
nueva historia el tiempo del despegue
económico un proceso que llevaría a esta
ciudad a convertirse en uno de los
territorios más libres y ricos de toda
asia e incluso de todo el planeta
[Aplausos]
[Música]
con 7 millones y medio de habitantes y
más de 1200 rascacielos
hong kong ha sido durante las últimas
décadas la gran referencia de
prácticamente todo el continente
asiático sin embargo esto ha cambiado
[Música]
veréis situado en pleno delta del río de
las perlas la gran zona tecnológica
industrial de china hong kong vio en
2018 como su vecina la ciudad de
shenzhen la conocida como el silicon
valley chino le arrebataba el primer
puesto como la ciudad con la economía
más grande del sur de china así es hong
kong ni siquiera es ya la mayor economía
entre las ciudades que integran el delta
del río de las perlas
sí a ver esto tiene una pequeña trampa
shenzhen tiene algo más de 10 millones
de habitantes entre 3 y 5 millones más
que hong kong que en términos per cápita
sigue siendo claro mucho más rica
pero amigos no importa porque esto es
algo que nos muestra cómo están
cambiando las cosas y como hong kong se
está quedando rezagada y no no es que la
economía de la ciudad no crezca sino que
sus vecinos crecen mucho más eso y que
mientras sus vecinos especialmente
shenzhen se han convertido en
importantes centros tecnológicos e
industriales donde han surgido
multinacionales tan importantes como
tensión de j ai weiwei con con se está
convirtiendo en un centro financiero
pero nada más y la pregunta que hoy cada
vez más personas se hacen es estaremos
ante el ocaso o ante el renacimiento de
hong kong si si habéis escuchado bien
blanco o negro atentos
la ciudad de los contrastes
amigos turno para vosotros os hago una
pregunta estáis preparados cuál pensáis
que es la ciudad del mundo con más ultra
ricos viviendo en ella con más personas
con patrimonios de más de 30 millones de
dólares vale seguro que muchos habéis
pensado en nueva york londres o tal vez
dubai verdad pues frío frío al río
habéis fallado más que el profesor
bacterio
de más a nueva york eclipsada como la
ciudad con la gente más extremadamente
rica hong kong es hogar de más gente
extremadamente rica que ninguna otra
ciudad en el mundo si hong kong hong
kong amigos es la ciudad con más
multimillonarios del planeta más de 10
mil residentes en esta ciudad tienen un
patrimonio de más de 30 millones de
dólares que como te quedas
así que puede que estéis pensando vamos
a ver si la ciudad está creciendo en
torno al 3% anual por cierto y es la
ciudad con más multimillonarios del
mundo entonces es que las cosas por aquí
van realmente bien no
pues sí pero no
amigos hong kong es un caso
paradigmático veréis por un lado es
aparentemente una ciudad pujante y rica
un centro financiero de primer orden
mundial para que os hagáis una idea la
bolsa de hong kong es gigantesca
en ella cotizan a día de hoy más de 2300
empresas con un valor de mercado total
de algo más de 4,1 billones billones
billones hispanos de dólares sin embargo
al mismo tiempo la ciudad tiene muchos
pero que muchísimos problemas
[Música]
sus residentes más pobres cada vez ganan
menos las tasas de mortalidad infantil
están creciendo el envejecimiento de la
población avanza a toda velocidad y un
porcentaje enorme de la población vive
en viviendas que no son propias de un
país desarrollado en muchos casos en
espacios minúsculos sin ni siquiera
ventanas o con ventanas sin ninguna
posibilidad de ventilación
vamos auténticos zulos
[Música]
amigos los espacios más claustrofóbicos
del mundo están aquí en hong kong y esto
tiene mucho que ver con que lo que
tendría que ser una acomodada clase
media realmente pues no lo sea casi la
mitad de los pisos de hong kong se
alquilan por dos mil quinientos
cincuenta dólares al mes el 70% de la
mediana de los ingresos por hogar según
la compañía de investigación demografía
el precio de las casas es veinte nueve
veces mayor que los ingresos medios por
hogar en hong kong comparado con las 3,9
veces de eeuu y las 43 de canadá está
que shigihara redactor de nikkei hacían
review
[Música]
pero amigos de todo esto ya os hablamos
en un pasado vídeo que os dejo en la
descripción y no lo siento ya os
adelanto que en todo esto no tiene nada
que ver ni el capitalismo salvaje ni la
condición de las grandes empresas ni el
exceso de población ni nada por el
estilo sino más bien el gobierno porque
en hong kong la inmensa mayor parte del
suelo y buena parte de las viviendas son
del gobierno son públicas pero un
momento no penséis que aquí termina todo
ni muchísimo menos en octubre de 2018 el
banco de inversión nomura presentó un
informe en el que alertaba de que el
riesgo de que hong kong pueda padecer
una crisis financiera en los próximos
años se ha disparado
hong kong se encuentra en una zona
peligrosa para una nueva crisis
financiera entre otras cosas porque
buena parte de la población ha asumido
préstamos enormes para poder acceder a
una vivienda de tal forma que un
porcentaje muy importante de los
residentes en hong kong particularmente
jóvenes profesionales están hasta el
cuello de préstamos hipotecarios
hong kong tiene mucha deuda y un mercado
inmobiliario sobrecalentado desde el
2008 los precios inmobiliarios se han
disparado un 125 por ciento en términos
reales y el ratio de deuda del sector
privado no financiero ha superado el 299
por ciento del pib y claro si a esto le
sumamos que los salarios apenas crecen y
que su economía es muy dependiente de
china cuyo crecimiento parece estar
desacelerándose el cóctel podría llegar
a ser de aúpa
me quiero marchar porque hong kong ya no
es lo que era mi plan es hacer un máster
en canadá encontrar un trabajo y empezar
una nueva vida
jonathan chand una estudiante hong kong
es de 24 años y es que claro eso de
matar es a trabajar con jornadas
interminables para vivir en una casa
minúscula y que encima tras pagar la
hipoteca o el alquiler el salario que le
quede a uno sea muy poca cosa pues como
que no que no invita mucho al optimismo
no os parece y luego ya de montar algo
ni hablemos porque cualquier sitio para
poder montar alguna empresa o algún
proyecto es carísimo así que peor que
peor pues eso es precisamente amigos lo
que cada vez más jóvenes hong kong es es
piensan mira
[Música]
según un estudio de 2018 de la chinese
university de hong kong el 51% de la
gente entre 18 y 30 años dice que están
pensando en marcharse del territorio ya
que si kihara redactor de nikkei hacían
review más de la mitad de los jóvenes
querrían vivir su vida en otro lugar no
me digáis que eso no es preocupante y
luego además también tenemos que tener
en cuenta la cada vez mayor injerencia
política de china y las crecientes
restricciones a las libertades políticas
hong kong prohíbe un partido pro
independencia mientras china refuerza su
control el hong kong national party es
prohibido en interés de la seguridad
nacional la libertad de prensa en hong
kong puesta en cuestión al denegarse
visa periodista del financial times en
fin amigos ya lo veis creo que no sería
descabellado decir que estamos ante algo
así como el ocaso del esplendor de hong
kong
[Música]
esa ciudad que deslumbró al mundo
convirtiéndose en todo un centro
financiero comercial e incluso cultural
[Música]
[Aplausos]
porque si durante décadas hong kong
incluso tuvo la tercera mayor industria
del cine de todo el mundo
ojo una industria de la que se llegó a
pensar que podría rivalizar con la
mismísima hollywood sin embargo esperar
un momento porque también hay quien
defiende que muy bien todo esto ya se ha
producido pero que ahora la ciudad está
a punto de experimentar todo un
renacimiento estarán los mejores tiempos
de hong kong al caer
[Música]
bien
el nuevo hong kong chino
nos lo hemos contado aquí visual
política al presidente chino todo eso de
un país dos sistemas no le hace ninguna
pero que ninguna gracia xi jinping está
empeñado en reducir la autonomía
política de hong kong pues bien para
lograrlo ha presentado un gran plan el
proyecto del área metropolitana de la
gran bahía
[Música]
el presidente chino quiere convertir
todo el delta del río de las perlas
donde se sitúan ciudades como hong kong
macao sense no one su en una gran área
metropolitana perfectamente conectada y
con una enorme integración económica y
ojo porque estamos hablando de más de 70
millones de personas y un pib que en
2030 según las estimaciones de morgan
stanley superarán los 3 billones de
dólares más grande que la economía del
reino unido
de momento los grandes proyectos de
infraestructuras ya son una realidad se
ha inaugurado un tren de alta velocidad
entre hong kong shenzhen y guanzhou y
también el puente más largo del mundo
entre hong kong y macao una conexión ni
más ni menos que de 55 kilómetros de
largo que por supuesto ha costado un
dineral
en cuanto a el problema que el gobierno
chino quiere que toda esta integración
permita poner fin a la autonomía de hong
kong y es que entre otras cosas aunque
formalmente son un país las regulaciones
las leyes y los tribunales son
diferentes en hong kong que la china
continental y entre los dos territorios
hay fronteras y aduanas
así que para que el área metropolitana
realmente funcionase pues parece que
tendría que producirse cierta
armonización lo que por supuesto en este
caso significa que hong kong sea cada
vez más china y que cuando expire su
autonomía en el año 2047 está pues o no
se renueve o se renueve de forma muy
limitada lo veis pues aún hay más
[Música]
en todo un giro espectacular de los
acontecimientos china ha nombrado a hong
kong como el centro nacional de
tecnología e innovación del sur de china
el gobierno chino ha comenzado a
financiar por primera vez proyectos de
investigación en las universidades de
hong kong ha exigido al gobierno de este
territorio que duplique su presupuesto
en i + d y que apruebe un programa para
atraer científicos y tecnólogos de todo
el mundo
pero por qué diantres hace esto china
pues amigos porque hong kong tiene una
enorme ventaja respecto al continente es
considerado una economía de mercado y no
está sujeto a restricciones a sus
importaciones es decir me explico las
empresas de hong kong pueden comprar lo
que les dé la gana incluidos bienes de
alta tecnología que pueden tener
aplicaciones tanto civiles como
militares productos que el gobierno y
las empresas chinas simplemente no
pueden comprar es decir que china quiere
aprovecharse del status de hong kong
para impulsar sus planes de desarrollo
tecnológico si lo consigue estupendo y
si eeuu y el resto de potencias
occidentales imponen restricciones a
hong kong y terminan con su estatus de
puerto libre puedes echar a la ciudad
aún más en manos de china que por
supuesto estará encantado de invertir
miles de millones en este territorio y
asumir el control total
[Música]
en fin amigos ya lo veis es difícil
prever si estamos ante el ocaso o ante
el renacimiento de hong kong pero lo que
sí parece claro es que hong kong cada
vez será más china pero ahora turno para
ti
crees que veremos los mejores tiempos de
hong kong déjame tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante ya sabes dale like y no
olvides suscribirte avisos polític que
es gratis un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Aplausos]
[Música]